[Music]
and today we'll be going over our next
part in the scotch course uh here with
the goring gambit so we'll get right
into it
okay
the goring gambit a very dubious line
for white though uh i should cover it
because it does arise from the scotch
opening and that is what we are
surveying throughout this series
so let's start off with what the goring
gamba is
so as always we get our scotch position
here e4 e5 and knight f3 knight c6
followed by d4
and here we're going to start looking
into black's main line with e takes d4
and here
the goring gambit is
4
c3
so after c3 black has a couple options
the main ones being knight f6
d5 and
the accepted variation with d take c3
but we're gonna go over some of black's
other tries here
um and what i can do if black doesn't go
for these options so the very first one
i want to
talk about is pawn to d3 now this may
look like something that resembles what
black could play in a smith mora gambit
but here this just isn't good black
isn't posing any problems white can
simply capture the pawn and after knight
f6 castles and d6 black has posed no
problems and white's position is fine
you'll see maybe move like rook to e1
bishop to f4 or g5
white should just have fine play here
but another try they have is queen to e7
and this is directly asking white what
are they going to do about the e4 pawn
so you do have to protect it if you
allow the queen to take with check it
does give black a lot of activity for
not so much um but i do want to say that
if you do take and queen e4 bishop e2
is is technically playable i just i
don't see
the the attraction to this but you can
go for it if you want otherwise defend
the pawn with bishop to d3 and after
they capture on c3 the obvious knight
captures you are giving up the pawn so
you do want to develop your pieces and
now after d6 castles knight f6
and bishop g5
black really only has one good move here
and that move is queen to d8 and the
point of queen to d8 is you're vacating
the e7 square for your bishop to develop
here to e7
if black plays anything else it's it's
gonna be a tough game like if they try
something like g6 trying to develop the
bishop this immediately loses tonight d5
where there's two attackers on the night
your queen is attacked and you're losing
uh a piece
so
black's gonna have a really tough time
if they try anything else even if they
try bishop e6 and castling long um
okay my engine's giving bishop b5 as a
good move but it's also queen a4
just saying i don't really want you to
castle but if you do i'm going to punish
you for it
by bringing my pieces in and now bishop
b5 with the threat of capturing the
knight and taking on a7
black doesn't need to be allowing this
so
um queen to d8
again if they try anything else they're
worse already here i think it's a little
tough as black just white can play
bishop to b5
everything's looking like it's pinned
and after the queen develops and the
rooks get into the game
i don't see any problems
the other alternative
i guess kind of serious alternative
black has to these main lines is knight
g to e7
um and you might see something like a
cosio type setup like cozier from the
lopez where they go knight g the e7
fiance the bishop but this pawn is not
on e5 anymore so it's not going to be a
closed position
and here
white is totally okay offering up the
pawn again they don't need to take back
right away they totally can and just be
happy with a pawn majority in the center
but i think more in the spirit is bishop
to c4
um
if they do take on d4 one line i do have
that black can follow up with is
striking back with d5 opening up this
center opening up the bishop um e5 shuts
down the center and then bishop to g4 so
bishop to e2 and knight f5 this does put
a lot of pressure on d4
um
i
theoretically white shouldn't go for
this but i find it is playable knight c3
and you have enough development
but okay okay bishop c4
d5 now so something that's very thematic
in a fried liver or
maybe even
some
crazy danish gambit
take on d5 knight takes on d5 and
castles
after castles black just develops with
bishop to e7 and after
knight takes d4
black can play knight e5 hitting the
bishop and the bishop can just drop back
really black should play knight e5 first
if they do castle i think white is going
to be a little bit better after
capturing on c6 and these doubled pawns
are going to be a long-term weakness
which
black doesn't have to allow
if they don't have to allow this i would
suggest 95
making sure these pawns are not doubled
so
black doesn't have this potential
weakness
in the position
and these are kind of all the
alternatives to our main lines that
we're going to look at here so
with that being said let's get into the
main lines
okay
so we're going to first take a look at
knight to f6
so knight to f6 totally playable move
and the most testing reply from white is
playing e5 this is just asking black you
know hey you just moved your piece i'm
attacking it where are you going to move
it to again are you going to burn a
tempo
and there's two moves here that are
possible knight to e4 and knight to d5
let's take a look at knight to e4 first
after knight to e4
i think white can get a little bit of an
edge here just playing queen e2
again harassing this knight and now
black really needs to play f5 or d5 to
maintain the knight if they move the
knight again to c5 then you just take on
d4 and black has burnt all of this time
really nowhere good for the knight to go
anyway
knight a6 is probably
the best materialistically
um but nice c3 white's just running away
with the development with the space this
is good like engines are saying the best
move here is knight to e6
and this just fails quickly to d5 so
that shows you how good this position is
for black so really they do need to play
f5 or d5
and i think
both
can can be looked at i think d5 is a
little more risky
i think according to the engines in
theory
uh so something like pawn takes and then
f5 to support the knight anyway and now
knight d4
if you're playing f5 to support the
knight anyway though might as well go f5
first
and the idea is that after pawn takes
you play d5 and now instead of having
this pawn on the king side that's
supporting your knight you have this
central pawn that's supporting your
knight so it's a little bit safer you're
still keeping your space in the center
i think this should be preferred
knight to d2 queen takes f6 just taking
care of the pawn
if white tries to go for this pawn after
bishop takes you're going to be facing a
lot of pressure on c3 because the bishop
adds to this attack
and it's gonna be a lot harder to catch
up in development so you really
shouldn't be going for this extra pawn
really white's main goal in most of
these lines is going to be develop as
fast as possible that's really what
we've been looking at with all of these
gambits here in the scotch you give up
the pawn develop everything as fast as
possible you'll be okay but if you do
waste time
like grabbing this pawn on g7 you will
be worse
so okay knight d2 queen f6 take on e4
take on e4
take on e4 again with check
and bishop e7 to block the check and
from here there's a couple good moves
white can play
i really like bishop to b5 and after
they take on c3
castles castles bishop takes c6 pawn
takes and bishop g5
and here this can lead to a a forced
line from black black's only good move
here
is bishop to f5 if they try moving the
queen anywhere uh you're just going to
lose this piece on e7 so
bishop to f5 counter attacking the queen
and okay queen e2 they move their queen
and you take on e7
and this looks like it's just you know a
piece it looks like white is a piece up
but there is bishop to d3 hitting our
own queen skewering to the rook
so after queen e3
um first they snapped his pawn on b2
we take on f8
they take on a1 queen we take
and takes and this is all
um been seen before
engines have shown this to be the way to
go i think it's a very interesting way
of getting into an end game where it
looks like all the pieces just get
traded both sides have a rook a minor
piece but white has the better structure
at the cost of a pawn so i think this is
a
very interesting end game to take a look
at
but okay knight e4 this is some sideline
black can play but the main move by far
is knight d5
and at the knight d5
white has a couple options here
so let's explore
the first option that i don't think is
as good for white is queen to b3
um really i think you do need to develop
these minor pieces first if you don't
it's going to be hard to coordinate a
very strong attack
but we are posing a problem we're asking
black you know where are you going to
put your knight so this knight typically
goes to b6 and we can take on d4
but now black can just play this kind of
slow d6 it's putting pressure on our
center opening up the bishop
and
okay we have to deal with it
again white should be focusing on
development for most of this so bishop
to b5 bishop e6 hitting the queen
you do need to resolve this but first it
does make sense to throw in this check
double up the pawns while we can and
then retreat the queen immediately
putting pressure on c6
black needs to protect their pawn so
queen d7
and castles kind of helps white almost
finish their development you still have
these queen side pieces
but those will develop very naturally um
moves like rookie one can also be
incorporated into the play and black's
just going to develop with moves like
bishop e7 and castle so
all of this should flow pretty naturally
and i don't think it's too hard for
players to find all of these moves and i
will say even though black does have
these doubled pawns
this is not the kind of attacking
position white is wanting when they're
playing a gambit this is going to be a
bit slower play
and
you know difficult to just whip up an
attack on the king because moves like
knight g5 are not available
this knight on c3 is pretty well
controlled by black's pieces
so
you can play this but i think black is
doing just fine
all right another alternative white has
after knight d5 is bishop to b5 and this
will actually turn into something that
resembles a martial attack in the roy
lopez i was actually a little surprised
to see that there was this kind of
resemblance but let's get into it black
can play a6 now
capturing the knight
you can do it but i don't know why you
would help black speed up their
development so you just go bishop a4
and if they go b5 so be it you just
retreat put some pressure on f7
but they will typically go knight b6
after knight b6 you can actually castle
here
and after knight takes queen takes
black should really play d5 and develop
but now we see
captures captures rook to e1 check
bishop to e6
knight d4
and queen h4 and this is where i said it
starts to resemble the martial attack in
the rui lopez you have both bishops
staring at the king side with the queen
and g3 is necessary to stop all the
mating threats if you play something
like h3
uh okay black's probably just going to
be better after
even queenside castle
um i
don't think
well okay the idea of castling is so you
can get the sacrifice to work so
white does face trouble so g3 is forced
and queen h3 with ideas of bishop d5
so
you take this piece
and the punk takes and you cannot take
this with check because watch out the
queen is hiding on h3
so don't hang your rook instead you can
put pressure on the center
and after castles
finish developing your pieces if you do
take a trade of queens is fine but i
think black is going to be
happy i believe they can just trade
rooks here
looks like rook trade may actually help
white
because of this extra pawn
but black doesn't have to go for this
they can go 95 trap your rook and then
get a trade when it benefits them
so bishop b5 is an option for white
and this can be kind of how black
responds i'm gonna be sharp i think
there are tricks both sides can play for
but the main move for white is just take
back on d4 right away with the pawn
you can take back
make sure you have this nice center
no
problems
but black has this this nice check
bishop to b4
and okay d6 is another option as well
this actually keeps more pieces on the
board so if
black doesn't like you know trading off
pieces and they want to maintain more
chances
um
then that's fine d6 is is good here and
as something like bishop b5 is always
met with a6 bishop a4 bishop e7 regular
developing moves here
we see both sides castle
the knight reroutes
bishop to c2 may be looking at h7
knight b4 hitting the bishop bishop goes
back to b3 this bishop is a very nice
attacker so we don't want to let their
knight trade off for it
now after bishop f5 we can finally start
getting more developing moves with rook
d1 a5 a3
and the knight goes towards the center i
think this is slightly better for white
but again with the pieces left on the
board definitely more chances for black
to fight as well
but bishop b4 check does lead to
equality
really white only has two moves
and it is not the attractive knight c3
this is where the knight wants to
develop naturally but this is losing on
the spot after knight captures pawn
captures and bishop captures check with
a fork
so
the only two moves you have are bishop
d2 or knight d2
both completely playable i think i like
going with the knight more
keep the bishop on the board it may be
of use one day and if black decides to
trade their bishop for their knight this
is typically a trade that is good for
white they do have the bishop pair so
black's obviously not going to want to
do that black's going to continue with
regular development by castling
and now we can start taking care of
these pieces on the queen side you play
a3
kind of provoke black to take if they
end up going backwards then bishop c4
hitting the d5 knight so this knight has
to move
you know and then castles like
black's pieces are being misplaced here
they're not coordinating well
so
uh they really should just take
and after takes play d6
and again d6 is just putting pressure on
the center looking to play bishop g4 and
that's exactly what we get bishop b5
bishop g4
h3 takes takes
and takes on e5
um it looks like the knight could take
on d4
but you do have this knight hanging and
after something like knight c2 check
king e2 white is actually better
here you take on a1 and now something
like bishop to d3 trapping this knight
it's very important you can retreat this
bishop trap the knight and stop black
from playing c6 which would fork your
own pieces
so uh white is actually better here um i
do want to point out that capturing on
a1 is a counter mistake by white because
of c6 and after bishop takes pawn takes
queen takes you're just you're down a
rook for a pawn
or sorry you're down the exchange
um
but yeah this is not
not what white is hoping for
so we will go back d takes e5 is the
best move
and now white will go with this sort of
thematic now captures on c6 doubling the
pawns and take on e5
and after rook to e8 finally on move 15
white king castle
after all this time give up the pawn on
e5
totally fine you're going to
develop with your rook and hit these
pawns
and that's what the rest of this endgame
is going to focus on is you know both
sides have two rooks and a minor piece
black has a knight and a slightly worse
structure
so this is going to be the imbalances
and i think white is doing just fine
though the engines will fight and say
this is equal
but this is what you can look forward to
if your opponent plays knight f6 on move
four
all right let's get into the next
section here
with
d5
so
our scotch game
the goring gambit
and they play d5
d5 is probably
the best way to refute the gambit um
or i guess decline not refute but
decline
but this this is pretty good for black
now
white has a few tries here but i do want
to cover the mistakes
you should not take on d4 because they
take on e4 your knight has to move
somewhere might as well go to g5 and try
and win the pawn back but now bishop to
b4 check and suddenly it's black who's
developing with initiative
knight to c3 and queen d5 will hold on
and it's it's tough i mean a3 hitting
the bishop a trade an h6 hitting our
knight and knight h3
bishop h3 gh3 and this this is the
problem is that our pawns
are not the prettiest pawns in the world
uh all all of them can be considered a
target and after knight g to e7 uh black
it just like
looks like they're doing good
black also has this idea of pawn to e3
looking to capture on f2 but also
looking to capture on h1
so
this this is another idea for them
um
i guess an illustrative example of that
is after queen d5 if white plays
something like bishop d2 trying to break
any pin
there is takes on c3 takes on c3
and okay you can play h6 first hit the
knight
and then capture
but now e3 is even more devastating
because you're hitting a piece and the
rook
so this is just completely lost for
white
another mistake white can make after d5
is playing e5 saying okay
i'm going to try and keep the center
closed
but black can take after knight takes
play d4
and now starting to
you know they're still attacking you you
have to respond trying to win the pawn
back and now bishop c5 holding on
and okay white just has to settle with
developing and getting pushed around
quite a bit
and i don't see
any problem whatsoever with black's
position yeah this pawn's over
or not really overextended but it's out
there
but i mean it's it's totally well
defended with no targets
nothing can really attack the bishops
right now
black should just be a little bit better
here
the last idea that white has aside from
the main line is bishop to d3
supporting the center pawn and i think
this is okay you are developing your
piece so it's not like the move is
completely useless it is a little
passive though uh black can play bishop
to g4
after white castles knight to f6 hitting
the e pawn again so white plays rook to
e1 to support it
get this rook onto a file that's about
to open
and now black really needs to play
bishop e7
um closing off this file before white
has the time to take on d5
um
white can play pawn to e5 here hitting
the knight and the knight has to retreat
and bishop to b5 and now we're looking
again for our usual captures on c6
double the pawn idea
and okay this is just an illustrative
line for how the rest of this can go
but
again white is going to focus on these
doubled pawns um
they can also give up
um
some of their king safety by doubling
their pawns on the king side as well and
this will give some play for black
um but i think that
in
in general this should be fine for both
sides
uh black kind of solidif or
fixes their structure rather
white still has um this doubled issue
here but you can also say you know open
file for the rook and i think there's
arguments to be had there
but
this is also a one that
looks fun to play
okay but after d5 white's uh main try is
just capture on d5 and black's only move
is to capture with the queen
uh there's no need to move your knight
and waste time just take the piece
normally this is a bad idea because
white can play knight to c3 but because
our pawn is on c3 it's not something
black needs to worry about
and now something like cb4
and here bishop to g4 our natural move
for black already setting black up to
castle queen side
um and now white can play bishop e2 or
knight c3 but it will transpose into
each other
if they go knight c3 first it's met with
bishop b4 and white doesn't have much
better than bishop e2
now
black can capture white can capture and
queen c4
now for those of you who don't know
world top 10 player levon aronian
has recently moved to st louis and this
was the position that he gave me i said
do you know anything about this he's
like oh yeah of course i'm top 10 in the
world of course i know this he wasn't
like that but he very kindly showed this
variation just said yeah no black black
has at least equality here
um so verified top 10 play um
white can capture
black isn't worried about the doubled
pawns um if black takes
this does allow white to castle so this
is part of the reason why it's okay to
let the pawns double is you are
preventing white from castling and this
king is stuck in the center
and really the only way to
i guess remedy this is to trade queens
and then after you know black castle's
queen side you can develop the rest of
your pieces fine and not have to worry
about getting checkmated in the center
so this does work out
no real big problems for black
yes doubled pawns
white has an isolated pawn
and both sides have have development
they have play so
this is probably the easiest way to just
say okay the goring gambit won't have
huge big play
but all right let's look at
the goring gambit accepted
so we've looked at the miscellaneous
fourth moves we looked at the
moves that decline the gambits but what
happens if black accepts and i think
there's going to be some sad news here
for any goring gambit players
because
while it could be a practical try
everything i looked at seemed uh to show
white doesn't get this huge crushing
edge so knight takes c3
there there is also bishop c4 and i will
give a little bit of credit to bishop c4
although it could be much better
they can take
white takes and now this is starting to
look like our
lovely danish gambit so dennis larue
would be proud
but
i don't think this is going to be as
good
um
white definitely has these ideas of
castle and queen side and h4 but
i i don't see where like huge sacrifices
on f7 come in like all the danish gambit
players really want i think you know
this is different black is just one move
faster than the normal danish
so okay we we will go back
um after bishop c4
they could take on b2 um
there are a couple transpositions i
think the big one is bishop to b4 here
and this actually transposes to the
london defense that we covered earlier
in the series so after b takes c3 bishop
a5 castles and bishop to b6 we've
already gone over the analysis for this
in a previous video and i think it
definitely deserves a look
other than bishop to b4
i guess there's a couple mistakes black
can make here bishop c5
um
bishop f7 king f7 and queen d5 check
actually
you know turns into the scotch gambit
which we've already covered or at least
scotch gambit like positions
and against bishop to e7 then there's
knight take c3 and then
probably the best they have is bishop to
b4 just going and pinning the knight and
moving the bishop again
um
if they don't
like okay let's say they play d6 trying
to develop queen to b3 putting pressure
on the position if knight h6 like you
just take on h6 and then f7 so
big problems if black is not careful
so that's why we see bishop to b4 now
queen to b3
takes with check and queen takes
um
this is what white can hope for
if black takes on c3 i think this is
going to be your ideal situation
um because black is so far behind in
development
but this is not usually the case
um there are better moves for black
um
for instance knight f6 here is
completely fine and normal development
with d6 bishop b7 and castle's king side
is going to be super solid
um just takes on on c3 with the knight
you have a game where
white is just a pawn down i think
uh what are some other moves white has
so
um i guess the mistakes that i didn't
that i didn't cover is if you take back
right away with the pawn
uh blacks is just already much better
the pawn structure is
dubious at best and how are you going to
expect to get compensation for your pawn
if you're not developing your pieces
you you really need to be developing
your pieces here so i don't want to see
anybody taking with their pawn
and there are some people who like to
try queen b3 right away but it's a
little bit slow the attack on f7 isn't
fast enough
um
we kind of transposed to this you know
danish gambit like position
and again it just it just isn't fast
enough to work on f7
so
um yeah those are the mistakes white can
make on move five
but really knight takes c3 is is what
most people play develop the knight
don't run your luck with trying to get a
better danish gambit it just doesn't
work
and here
black has two moves
it looks like um d6 is the first one
it's a bit solid black is intending on
playing bishop to e7 and using it
defensively rather than the option where
they go bishop to b4 and they pin the
knight
so d6 is going to be a bit more
defensive
and
this can lead to a sharp rather forcing
line so i think both both sides need to
be prepared here
white starts off with bishop to c4
knight to f6 developing on the king side
and queen to b3 with this attack on f7
um and now
queen to d7 should be preferred to e7
you want to make sure e7 is cleared for
your bishop so you can castle
but this move
you're blocking your bishop you're
blocking your knights from coming back
if it needs to
and white can take advantage of this by
playing knight g5 putting more pressure
on f7
to combat this pressure knight to e5
will defend and simultaneously attack an
attacker
don't hear that one much
but now white can play something like
bishop b5
c6 hitting the bishop and now f4
f4 is a way to try and break through
you can trade off minor pieces
takes on e5
and now
um taking on b5 with the queen is a
mistake
i think a queen trade is going to be
just fine the bishop develops with check
trades itself off and then castles
should be
be just fine for black they're just up a
healthy pawn they have a bishop for a
knight
so instead of taking on b5
white should just play bishop e3
bishop to e3 just developing looking to
bring a rook to the center
and black has this
this nice resource a5 and this is what
keeps them in the game
after white castles the point of a5 is
to play a4
and now trade the queen
or at least offer the trade it's not
necessary
black can definitely play bishop to d6
here
um
white should probably keep the queens on
the board they are down a pawn so
keeping the queen will help generate
chances
uh and now just to keep the position
together rook a5
rook a5 rook a to c1
h6
and now really
the only move to keep white in this game
um with
i guess as close to equality as possible
all the other moves i'm getting at least
minus one and a half four but rook takes
f6 a exchange sacrifice to double the
pawns on the king side
knight to f3
and after b6
this is where the game will start now
white has a few deviations
some mainly focusing on queen f2
hopefully looking at f6 and b6 there's
also ideas of knight h4 to f5
and king to h1 just a waiting move is
also fine as well
so
i'm just showing this because this is
something that both both players should
kind of know where the game can go black
needs to be you know watchful for this
f4 push opening up the file and the
exchange sack
at the same time white needs to know
when
when to push when to offer a trade of
queens and all that stuff so
um yeah d6
the other option they have is bishop c5
this is kind of an alternative to bishop
b4
and now bishop c4 and now we're starting
to see this idea of bishop
sacrifices in queen d5 so d6 it stops
this tactic if white takes there's no
queen d5 because the bishop is protected
um and
so after castles and knight ge7 both
sides can develop naturally and neither
side has proven a significant advantage
yet
but okay the main move here
bishop to b4 i think is going to be a
way to shut down white's play
white can try two moves bishop g5 is
interesting um but black can take
um bishop e7 just blocking is also
equalizing right away but bishop takes
c3
again these pawns
this is not what white wants they don't
want these pawns to become isolated and
lonely it's going to be harder to hold
on to them and already being down upon
the more weaknesses you have the worse
your position is
uh so knight ge7 blocking the attack on
the queen bishop c4 and d6 black has no
problem developing and white just
doesn't have this compensation for the
pawn
so that's why white tries bishop to c4
and d6 can be played here
now black is intending on trading pieces
on c3
and they play d6 to prepare knight to f6
without getting kicked by e5
so if they go knight f6 right away e5
actually holds some merit for white so
don't allow this just play d6 open up
your bishop to go to g4 and now your
knight can go to f6 without being
harassed kind of like the idea in the
open sicilian is you play d6 to prevent
this e5 push
if black decides to take on c3 instead
of pushing d6
this will normally transpose into
a line where they play d6 anyway such as
you know right here
um
and yeah if they try knight f6 just met
with e5
so d6
and now white white should just castle
break the pin try and develop
they can try knight g5
i don't know if i have faith in it again
black captures
i i just i'm not a fan of this structure
for white but i i i will leave it at
that
um and black can just kind of kick all
the pieces around now again there is
this f4 idea of trading off miners
and then getting the f file to work for
you later
um
and there is this line
which you know i'll show i won't talk
about it too much
because i don't think white should go
for this idea but they do end up with a
bishop for the night the problem is the
pawns are really weak and this bishop
is kind of countered by these pawns so
yeah i don't like this for white again i
think white should just castle break the
pin
um queen b3 also doesn't quite work just
because of captures captures in queen f6
offering the queen trade it's hard to
tell what compensation that white is
claiming to have
so
castles and now this is black's last
chance to capture on c3 because the pin
was broken if white is allowed to move
this knight maybe to d5
i think they're going to be just fine so
black should take get this weakness be
up upon and secure an advantage this way
um if e5 is ever played you're okay
trading the knights
and okay if if white trades here there's
in a worse end game now they're down two
pawns they can take on f7 but
okay like i think black is just better
so queen b3 looking to win f7 with check
queen e7 protecting east or f7
and now like bishop a3 hitting the queen
blocks with c5 bishop b5 check
and blocks with the bishop takes takes
takes
okay and this is fine and i think the
the last part here white can go for is
um well okay sorry there's it's black's
turn there's a huge idea here um knight
to e4 hitting the bishop hitting the
pawn on c3 threatening d2 with a fork
so this one is a big idea the way you
stop this move
um i wanted to point this out is
um counter intuitive
is queen to a3
this was not a natural move to me
blocking the pawn but this does stop all
of the threats knight to d2 is met with
a rook to d1
um and the bishop is now protected
c3 is still protected so i did want to
make sure i pointed that one out now
queen c6 putting pressure on the bishop
um white does have the time to take on
a7 here
but they need to be careful um because
you know this is not not a friendly pin
so b6 trapping the bishop trying to win
this bishop
um with just enough time that after rook
fe1 and f6
queen b4 and you can give up this bishop
because of this knight so the knight
takes on f2 they're gonna lose it anyway
and queen takes b6 will
will be good enough for white to pull
out
of this you know tough position
and okay
while the material is equal i think i
still
definitely prefer black's position the
pawns are much healthier than whites and
i don't think white is actually going to
be strong enough
or sorry not strong enough but it's
going to be much more difficult for
white to
promote one of these two pawns rather
than black slowly pushing this you know
swarm of pawns to promote the e-pawn
so
i think that this
you know this is kind of how the
position can look probably in the best
best case for white
but i think that uh even though white
has survived his pawns are are worse and
it's going to be difficult to win i
think the the play here is going to be
to play for a draw
but okay i'm sure i'm missing a lot of
tricks white has here
um so if you do play the goring gambit
feel free to leave those tricks down in
the comments section below for everyone
else to take a look at i always like to
go through the comments and see what i
missed if there was a lot of stuff i
missed i like to add it onto the video
make sure you know people can see it
otherwise this is the goring gambit i
don't think it's that great for white
and black is pretty comfortable if they
have done their homework
so all right that is the goring gambit
next time we'll be getting into the main
lines of the scotch this dinette and
then we have queen h5 and our our main
lines with knight f6 and bishop c5
alrighty you guys have a good one good
luck with your chest i'll see you next
time